deux situés dans le quartier 17 mar à
elancourt ce campus numérique propose
quatre cursus suivi par 50 stagiaires
particularité de ces formations elles
sont accessibles à toutes et tous et
gratuites pour certains le monde se
transforme le monde change tout
s'accélère et on se rend bien compte
qu'aujourd'hui 80% des emplois qui se
créent ont un rapport avec le numérique
donc il faut augmenter l'employabilité
numérique notamment des saint quentinois
deux organismes de formation ont pris
possession des lieux
il propose des parcours visant les
métiers les plus en tension dans le
secteur du numérique
tout le monde recherche des développeurs
donc des programmeurs des gens qui font
du codage donc ils sont capables de
parler la langue des machines et de leur
faire faire un peu ce qu'ils veulent
donc il ya une partie développeurs web
et une partie qui est développeur plutôt
orientée sur les données tout ce qu'on
appelle le big data et donkey et
permettre d'apprendre à manipuler ces
données à les mettre en forme et à les
utiliser pour les entreprises on est
deux acteurs de l'économie sociale et
solidaire on est tous les deux sur des
formations gratuites
donc c'est très bien pouvoir faire une
communauté d'apprenants un peu plus
large aussi et que les apprenants
simplon les apprenants pop school soit
ici dans les mêmes locaux puissent
pourquoi pas partagée au delà des locaux
des projets des interactions à la
prochaine rentrée ce campus numérique à
elancourt accueillera une centaine de
stagiaires